i spoke to many of these
muslim former muslim agnostic muslim
moderate muslim whatever you want to
call them guys saying
if we don't take the lead in breaking
this thing open
the countries that we have fled to are
going to look like
the countries we fled from
it's extraordinary so so part two um
which we've sort of hit on a little bit
but the european establishment
abrogates responsibility for women's
safety now we thought
that these liberal societies were
supposed to stand up for their women
but we're not seeing this i mean
everyone knows what happened in germany
a couple years ago on new year's
there's a lot of examples of in essence
these countries
throwing women under the bus in the name
of diversity or something like that
so about 10 years ago maybe a little
more maybe a little less
i had a discussion with my friend
christopher caldwell
who wrote a lot about immigration in
europe and the consequences intended
unintended positive and negative
and i said to him um he said we were
talking about european values
and i said to him you know one day
the europeans they probably won't stand
up for freedom of speech they won't
stand up for this value they won't stand
up for that value
but you know what when their women are
threatened
they'll stand up for women's rights and
he just took on that expression of
you know the wise old man and he said
you're so optimistic i don't know if
they
stand up for anything wow and
i'm just i i'm terrified to say
that he was right and i was wrong do you
think that was just
naivete on your part i mean you you come
from a place where you you knew about
these things i mean do you think that
was just sort of a
an optimist way of looking at the world
that oh when it really starts affecting
these people they will do something
or do you view human nature a little
differently after a couple years
i think the first thing i'll say is
because i was surrounded by european
women who are strong
and who had fought for all of this stuff
and gained it and took it for granted i
thought
they would be first in line to say this
is
unacceptable um
so i think that maybe it's
it blew me uh let me see i don't know
it misdirected me into thinking
that you know there's gonna be i know
there were all sorts of
confrontations happening but when you
come for the little girls and you come
for the women
you know society is going to say that's
a red line
and so i have to confess that i got that
wrong
i think i also got wrong the class
element
that wealthy middle class women
with university degrees
organize their organizing around causes
such as the glass
ceiling they want to be ceos they want
to
be on board leaderships and stuff like
that
they want to be chancellors and prime
ministers and that's what excites them
and there was a lot of conversation
about
child care so that you could have 50
percent of parliament be
female and that's what
middle class women are preoccupied with
and
i didn't realize that there was that
disconnect between working-class women
and uh middle-class wealthier women and
that's what i'm seeing now
and maybe that's why in the beginning
when we were just talking about
immigrant women muslim women
you know stuff that they're subjected to
uh most people were looking away because
it was you know not just foreign
and they didn't understand it
um but it was also you know it wasn't
their problem
right so that's what's so fascinating
about it because when it was just sort
of their
problem in their in their own ghettos
sort of separate okay that's one thing
but then when you add this element of
cultural relativism where you're no
longer allowed to say i mean this is
what we've seen we see women get raped
on the streets we
we read about grooming gangs although
you don't really hear anything in
mainstream media here
but if you read those things and you
well you can't say
you can't you're not allowed to say that
those people those specific people who
hold those specific views
that those views are worse than our
views everything's equal
everything is equal and they've been
saying that for a very long time
um david i spoke to tinos henandagi who
is
a swedish economist a long time ago i
should have mine again
yeah he told me he was on my podcast
i interviewed him for the book he said
to me
that there is an interesting development
that the people who are actually coming
out now and talking about these things
are immigrant men and women
and i asked him do you think that there
is a possibility that working class
women
local native white women could actually
ally
with immigrant women and and immigrant
families who've had enough of the crime
who've had enough of the disruption you
know remember they fled their campaigns
in searching for better life in search
of stability and predictability
and they're now being confronted with
this mess
what is the likelihood that working
class
families men and women but especially
women
and immigrant women could actually form
an alliance and fight this thing
uh he's optimistic on that he said in
sweden
you know they're the ones at the
forefront of people who are trying to
break open the taboos
are immigrant women so immigrant women
immigrant men
immigrants i spoke to mustafa tang shiri
i spoke to
hamad abdul samid in in germany i spoke
to many of these
muslim former muslim agnostic muslim
moderate muslim whatever you want to
call them guys saying
if we don't take the lead in breaking
this thing
open the countries that we have
fled to are going to look like the
countries we fled from
yeah and then of course as you know our
our friend majin nawaz who started
quilliam in the uk
who hates him it's the lefties it's the
lefties that hate him
right i mean he who's always trying to
cancel him even right now trying to get
his radio show off
lbc it's the lefties because they're now
trying to frame him
a muslim man from egypt uh as a racist i
mean it's
you know a little something about this
from your own story
he went to egypt when he was radicalized
but i think his heritage
probably lies somewhere in pakistan um
but it's exactly it's exactly yeah it's
exactly it's the demonization of
anybody who wants to break this open and
i think
that they are becoming less and less
successful because you now see the rise
of the far right
you see the rise of populist parties
you see this despair again i want to go
as an example to the to the president of
france
who has to you know he is he has to
defend
his presidency from marie le pen
um and developments like that
and the far left will continue to try
and
silence everyone but they're not
succeeding because people are
suffering i'm you know what the book
tries to do is
some of the animals that's a description
of real human
pain and so the more you say to
i i told you some of the victims they
say
i'm not far right i i i'm for
immigration i work for left-wing parties
but i've been raped
i've been subjected to this type of you
know sexual violence
and i don't want that right of course
well you don't want everyone to have to
be raped
in essence to wake up right like that's
what we're trying to stop here
that's what we're trying to stop we're
trying to stop the crimes and so the i
think there's we are maybe at a moment
in some european countries more than
others i think that's where denmark got
to it's a smaller population
austria they were talking about a rape
epidemic i mean just
think about that before the pandemic
they were talking about
a rape epidemic and that's what forced
the authorities to do something about
these things and so
these attempts at silencing people by
labeling them taking away as you
describe magics
podcasts and platforms and things like
that it's not going to work
it's not going to and i'm old enough let
me tell you this
i mean i love the internet
i'm a proponent of the internet
i think it's one of the best things that
happened in my lifetime
but i'm old enough to know when there
was no internet
when more cell phones um when very few
people had landlines
and yet we communicated so you can you
know
the tech giants can say i'm gonna take
your platform away
good luck with that but people will find
ways to communicate
but the sad story is if you say
we are going to marginalize and silence
certain views
you then have to deal with the
unintended consequences of censorship
and censorship
never works never worked if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell